Merry Christmas America in the lobby of
financial peace Plaza Bryant and Tiffany
are with us hey guys how are you hey how
you doing
Merry Christmas where do you guys live
we're from Greenville but we live in
Greer South Carolina that'll work cool
welcome welcome good to have you I
assume you're in Nashville at least
partially to do a debt free scream we
are cool what else are you doing while
you're here that was it no came up here
for a debt free scream and we stopped by
the Opry Mills Mall that was about it no
that's that's a good place to lose some
money right yes a couple of times share
people in there yeah oh my gosh Oh fine
so how much debt of you guys paid off so
seventy nine thousand three hundred and
eighty four dollars and fifty-seven
cents
way to go how long did this take you
since by twenty three months Wow yes now
making what kind of money start off at
fifty thousand now we make over a
hundred thousand no so in two years you
doubled your income yeah my wife she was
looking for work and she found it ah
that'll do it okay that'll do it put two
people to work instead of one that'll
that'll double the income I got it helps
that's fun it surely does that still is
a lot to pay off in two years did you
sell some stuff you smoked we sell some
small stuff like the trade meals and
just small clothes and consignments
places things like that but nothing big
no big cars or anything like that it's
overtime man you guys have been on beans
and rice haven't you yeah that's amazing
so what happened 23 months ago that made
you decide to get out of debt and
believe you could I think when we did
our income tax and saw what we made and
what we had in the bank and how much
debt we were in we finally said enough
was enough
hey man that'll do it I don't do it so
what do you say the keys are I mean you
paid off almost eighty thousand bucks in
two years that's impressive
and what are you thinking what do you
tell people when they they say how did
you do that
a lot of over time this was working the
budgeting yes you keep on yeah a lot of
couponer you finally know just telling
yourself no you know just being a
growing up and just
you want you want a whole lot of stuff
but sometimes you've gotta just wait
wait until you can naturally afford it
absolutely well more than that I mean
you were not going what kind of debt was
this what was the big one I think my
still home yeah
how much was on the car my card there's
about seven thousand dollars it was
maxed out okay all right wow this is
impressive this is impressive
what do you so you so you tell people
the key is the budget then yeah the
budget now and living on it together so
was it harder than you thought it was
going to be or easier than you thought
it was going to be when you started I
think it was easier once I was able to
sit down and actually say okay I'm
committed we can do this and he was on
board from beginning the other hand so
it was his idea yes he comes home and
and what convinced you to try it well my
brother I went to his house one night
and he just bought a four he's about
Toyota Tundra and I asked him how much
was his payment you know I'm used to
people having payments on their cars and
he said don't tell me people with it but
I parked I bought a cache and I asked
him how do you do that and he said I've
been doing this this Dave Ramsey thing
so I went to work that night at the
nursing home and um looked you up I saw
you had an app and I downloaded the app
and I listened to you for a while and
bought the book and that was it hmm
so is it so Tiffany how'd he convince
you to do this just look at works he
showed me the numbers and said we can do
it and well she kind of got your brother
over there
you going look at him he did it yes yeah
there's a little nothing like having a
walking talking testimony right in your
family all right yeah that's that's
pretty neat well congratulations you
guys how does it feel to not have any
payment it feels good three and a half
years cool very cool and yeah I assume
you've been in debt the entire time oh
yeah yeah but not the last two years
you've been working your way out and now
you're done forever it completely
changes your family tree doesn't it and
she's been along for the ride - so we've
been having to tell her no for
everything so she's excited too
my son right there Bryce he is - all
right baby baby we fake-ass form that's
good
keeps them from getting repossessed all
right you guys you got a beautiful
family on prank one of your
congratulations very well done merry
Christmas to you Brian and Tiffany
$79,000 paid off in 23 months making 50
now making $100,000 a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
that's funny the little guy he got all
in trance there at the last that was
awesome
in the he wasn't sure what all the
applause was for you unsure what he did
that's great I loved it very very well
done you guys very well done
man so you can do this stuff folks